In the binary classification section,
we learned about decision trees which
were used to predict binary variables.
They do this by splitting the data and
creating the largest difference at
the percent between the target group.
Well guess what, they can also
be used to predict non-binary
classification data and we'll be using
this for our new business problems.
Since we already learned
the foundation of decision trees,
let's flip over to Alteryx
to build this model out.
Now, what we are going to do is
build a decision tree over Alteryx,
interpret the results and
validate the model.
If you recall,
the goal of this analysis is to
predict what mode of transportation
the 40% of employees who did not
respond to this survey actually use.
Since we have already built out
a decision tree, go ahead and
bring in the data and
build this model out yourself.
We can then validate
the model afterwards.